Newt Gingrich is with us one thing that
has puzzled me and you know you said
something that every model you've ever
known has been thrown off this election
you know we weren't supposed to pick up
seats in 2020 I forgot what do we we
picked up 16 I think in 2020 nobody
expected that uh here Republicans win
the popular vote by about 5 million
votes and picking up fewer than
everybody thought but still getting a
majority your thoughts
well I mean first of all the Democrats
were brilliant at targeting where to put
resources I I talked two days ago with
Adam laxalt who said you know he was
ahead and was matching the Democrat with
advertising until two weeks ago and
suddenly people decided he'd won so they
cut off his money and she outspend him
three to one the last three weeks so I
think you've got to go and look at some
of these key places in the case of
balduck the candidate New Hampshire
Mitch McConnell himself ran four million
dollars in ads attacking ball duck in a
way in the primary in a way that I think
permanently made it harder for him to
win so some of this is One race at a
time the the bigger story I think is
that Kevin McCarthy went out and
recruited new people this will be the
most diverse house Republican party in
history the most women the most veterans
the most minorities and in fact uh if we
had kept our incumbents you know in both
94 when we won and in 2020 when Kevin
picked up 16 seats we didn't lose a
single incumbent well if that were the
case now we'd be much closer to 230 and
so one of the things we have to do is go
back and look at why did certain
incumbents lose was it reapportionment
was it a bad campaign you know what was
happening there what I've seen tonight
you know and then cliff and I were with
Kevin on Election night I'd been
campaigning with him for three days just
getting a feel for what was going on we
were all sort of in a State of Shock
because we all thought as you pointed
out when you look at the generic ballot
when you look at the national vote
pattern when you look at Florida and New
York for example returning huge
majorities you had to have a sense that
this was going to be a great night and
then it wasn't however let me point one
other thing out Sean I got curious about
this Kevin's going to be somewhere
between 218 and 224 there have been
seven congresses since 1916 in which the
majority was in the 220 to 223 range
including of course Pelosi's last
majority so Kevin will not be faced with
something unprecedented Denny hastert
was at 221 in one election and 223 in
another election so you can govern with
a pretty narrow majority it's
challenging it's exhausting It's Tricky
but it can be done and I think the
Republicans are going to be in charge
and as you know passing over that gavel
from Pelosi to McCarthy is an enormous
shift in the balance of power in
Washington it is you cannot overstate
the importance of this you really can't
it really is that big look I understand
people looked at you know historically a
president's first term ends with uh loss
in in Congress and in this case it it
turned over the house us
um I cannot I I never understood I
looked at every one of these Senate
races and I know I just said you know
what these these are all toss-up States
these are all hard to win you got to run
the table on these and I'm seeing this
what I call Accelerated migration
accelerated by covid and and shutdowns
and parents wanting their kids to have
in class learning and this Mass Exodus
to the Carolinas Tennessee Texas and and
especially Florida and I'm looking at
that and I'm thinking you know what
there's a lot to be learned here the sad
part is the these red States will be
redder but these toss-up states are
going to be harder for Republicans to
win the presidency we have about 30
seconds
yeah I don't know if that's true in the
long run in the end the American people
outweigh any kind of geographic line
we're gaining with Latinos we're gaining
with Asian Americans we're beginning to
gain with African Americans I think it's
very likely two more years of Biden
we're going to have a great 2024.
all right Newt Gingrich thanks for being
with us hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else